grâce à notre équipe mobilisée ici en
régie on va recueillir dans toutes vos
questions on a déjà commencé à le faire
d'ailleurs merci à ceux qui ont déjà
participé on va donc essayer de répondre
comme d'habitude un maximum d'entre vous
alors avant de retrouver marc perelman
qui est donc mon acolyte sur la chaîne
anglophone le présentateur de france
fund twenty twenty two de campaign donc
l'équivalent de france 2022 l'heure du
choix sur la chaîne anglaise avec qui
donc on va décrypter cette campagne j'ai
le plaisir pour débuter ces laves d'être
avec mon ami et collègue clovis casali
vous le connaissez déjà peut-être du
premier live 1 il avait déjà participé
salut clovis ça va merci de nous
rejoindre encore pour cela et c'est
hyper sympa de devenir à nouveau alors
je le rappelle clovis pour france 24
couvre l'extrême droite donc à la fois
le candidat du parti reconquête eric
zemmour enfin sa campagne plutôt et du
couvre aussi
l'autre pour la marine le pen la
candidate du rassemblement national tu
étais d'ailleurs hier à ceux à 7 quand
démonstration de force on peut le dire
quand même de eric zemmour place du
trocadéro à paris qu' une place assez
symbolique pour les campagnes on va y
revenir tout d'abord est ce que tu peux
nous raconter un petit peu l'ambiance de
ceux de ce grand meeting c'était chaud
chaud déjà les températures élevées et
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
présentes pour eric zemmour il y avait
des gens un peu de partout en france on
a rencontré un groupe du lot et garonne
dans le sud ouest un autre groupe de la
sarthe il avait mobilisé énormément de
bus pour faire venir les supporters les
partisans plutôt d'eric zemmour pour
qu'il soit là le jour j parce que tu as
raison de parler de deux termes de
démonstration de force c'est ce qu'eric
zemmour essayer de montrer avec ce grand
rassemblement donc si vous me le drapeau
français jamais vu autant de drapeaux
français sur la place et ça chante et
des des slogans qu'on a l'habitude
d'entendre plutôt rassemblement national
et à l'époque au front national tip on
est chez nous on est chez nous ici c'est
la france
et bien sûr des zemmour président tu
peux imaginer c'est que des gens qui
sont à fond derrière eric zemmour et
avant son grand discours y avait aussi
marion maréchal tu sais qui a retrouvé
qu'un roger ans la nièce de marine le
pen
à la tête donc du rassemblement national
qui a fait défection en tout cas j'ai un
peu travaillé un peu trahi sa tante et
le rassemblement national pour aller
chez eric zemmour alors elle a pris la
parole tu avais aussi guillaume
pelletier qui lui est un transfuge du
parti à l'est républicain ancien porte
parole du mouvement de centre-droit en
tout cas on va dire de la droite
traditionnelle qui a choisi eric zemmour
ce l'ancien journaliste si différents et
qui essaye de faire éruption mais c'est
pas si finir les droites le cas c'est ce
qu'il a dit ce qui va sans doute faire
il a c'est vraiment de faire une union
des droite de l'extrême droite jusqu'à
jusqu'au centre droit lui dit qu'il va
être le chef de la france des patriotes
du camp des patriotes qui va sauver la
france que la civilisation française est
en danger parce que pour lui eh bien les
valeurs de la france la religion n'est
plus respectée pour lui un problème avec
l'expansion de l'islam ici en france
hier ils étaient un peu plus modéré que
d'habitude il a dit que les musulmans en
gros enfin que certains musulmans ne
veulent pas être français ou non
sa similaire voilà mais d'habitude il
encore plus offensif là il a juste dit
qu'elle avait un problème sur
l'expansion de l'islam en france alors
on est une première question alors ça
concerne de manière plus générale la
politique de la france vis-à-vis des
migrations tu parlais justement du
programme d'eric zemmour avec lui du
coup pour rebondir un peu sur cette
question d'un internaute sur facebook a
priori est ce que les choses vont
changer en tout cas merci eric son
président parce que en tout cas eric
zemmour il a encore plus extrême que
marine le pen sur les questions
d'immigration
la une de ses dernières idées c'est un
ministère de la reynie gras sur la rive
renvoyés dans leur pays tous les
étrangers qui seraient délinquants
fichier est ce qu'ils auraient commis
des délits ici en france il vise un
million de personnes donc à renvoyer
dans leur pays d'origine il dit pas
comment il va le faire voilà sur la
durée du quinquennat en cinq ans c'est
déjà compliqué on sait déjà que le
gouvernement français renvoie certains
délinquants étrangers mais pas dans ces
chiffres là pas dans ses nombreux là et
bien sûr il a été énormément a critiqué
pour ça des gens disent que c'est un
faisable que c'est une une mesure
démagogique la part d'eric zemmour et
c'est aussi un peu on al'impression une
dernière tentative pour lui de remonter
un petit peu dans les sondages parce
qu'on avait tant parlé il stagne alors
même qu'il arrive à recruter des poids
lourds chez ses concurrents mais dans
les sondages il monte pas il est à
lorient ni où la balle hors il est
environ 10 % c'est compliqué à dire ce
que ça change les sondages qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'en tout cas il est très
très loin derrière emmanuel macron le
président de la république sortant et
même marine le pen alors qu'au début de
la campagne il disait que marine le pen
is d'impôts au coude à coude un moment
disait que marine le pen c'était fini
que c'est lui qui allait représenter
cette union de la droite et qu'il allait
être au second tour alors les sondages
dit ça il faut dire quand même que quand
on parle avec l'entourage d'eric zemmour
eux sont convaincus
qu'il sera au second tour et qu'en fait
les médias les élites les journalistes
tout ce corps d'opposants pour et bien
sont en train de manipuler un petit peu
l'opinion est d'ailleurs tu montres à
l'heure en off qu'il y avait pas mal
d'hostilité
ses clics et ses meetings alors on
parlait aussi avec d'autres collègues
humaines chez mélenchon ils ont des
problèmes mais nous moi je me suis fait
à traiter d'islamophobe gauchistes
pendant le rassemblement hier il ya un
couple tu les as croisé dans la rue tu
dirais que ce sont des gens très bien un
couple un petit peu bien habillé la
cinquantaine mari et femme et le mari
vient me voir il me dit ah vous êtes
france 24 je dis oui abbas et la chaîne
des islamo gauchiste voilà j'ai pas trop
le temps de lui répondre ce que j'avais
un duplex cinq minutes après sinon
j'aurais peut-être pris une minute pour
pour mettre les points sur les i et il
mais je dis oui c'est ça et il me dit
bah vous savez vous fait le plus le
métier le plus laid au monde à ne pas
demander quel était son métier mais je
crois que c'était un peu désagréable
parfois dans ces rassemblements ça
libère la parole et joie ils viennent
naturellement insulté magistrats et si
ton banquier quitte à les insulter chez
un boulanger lambda vexé il ya vraiment
une perte de respect parfois on le voit
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est
assez dingue parce que dans toute
société quand les journalistes sont
critiqués autant emma c'est jamais très
bon signe pour la démocratie parce que
les journalistes qu'on le veuille ou non
il essaie d'être objectif pour la
plupart est une société avec des médias
libres qui s'expriment comme c'est le
cas moi jamais demandé de dire quoi que
ce soit j'ai jamais vu un patron qui m'a
dit faut parler de ça faut pas parler de
ça faut que tu me couvre un événement
comme ça c'est bien que tu fasses répond
aujourd'hui à l'armée c'est important
les choses soient claires aux questions
bons basiques mais tout de même macron
peut-il être emmanuel macron peut-il
être réélu bas tout est possible en tout
cas selon les sondages il est largement
en tête emmanuel macron il a été aussi
renforcé semblerait par cette crise en
ukraine où il a montré en tout cas qu'il
a une stature d'homme d'état en tout cas
ils conversent avec poutine avant le
début de la guerre pendant la guerre il
y a vraiment pris les choses en main il
à said de donner une certaine voie à la
france est aussi profitent du fait qu'il
est qui était d'ailleurs en oui j'ai
entendu qu'il ya pas mal de questions
dont la cruelle pensez vous justement
pour rebondir sur exactement ce que tu
es en train de dire pensez vous que
l'implication des manuels macron dans le
conflit en ukraine pour être allé dans
son sens pour la présidentielle c'est
une question posée par fréjus masters
sur instagram merci beaucoup fréjus
master de nous l'avoir posée bon c'est
un peu ce que tu étais en train de dire
en riant il en est sorti à son avantage
et tout cas la france a aussi la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne et donc donne ça donne de la
voix à la france est paré et par là même
au président emmanuel macron alors en
général ça compte quand il y avait ce
genre de crise ça dépend comment c'est
gérer mais il semblerait pour emmanuel
macron ça se passe plutôt bien dans les
sondages depuis le début de la guerre
après c'est très difficile à dire mais
aussi emmanuel macron a réussi dans un
sens à tuer la gauche regarde les
résultats à gauche les niveaux
extrêmement faibles anne hidalgo 2 5%
mélenchon ça va de mieux en mieux mais
c'est quand même compliqué les verts ont
des résultats en baisse et lui manuel
macron est tellement au centre qu'il
arrive à prendre à gauche mais aussi à
droite et on le voit avec les mauvais
résultats de valérie pécresse même s'il
faut bien le dire et valérie pécresse
certaines de ces voix sont allées à eric
zemmour et peut-être même à marine le
pen est en tout cas valérie pécresse
semblerait convainc pas vraiment dans
son camp et a du mal à séduire on va
dire petite réaction clovis sur tes
propos alors c'est pas une question
c'est plutôt un commentaire d'accord
donc d'un internaute qui nous dînons
reconquête n'est pas d'extrême droite
mais de droite conservatrice c'est ce
que dit le partir aux conquêtes mais bon
quand il parle de rémunération quand il
ya des discours sur une civilisation en
péril certaines personnes vont te dire
bah c'est juste une simple constatation
c'est un constat basse a souvent été
catalogués en tout cas extrême droite
quand il parle autant de l'islam de la
religion quand on regarde tout
simplement les gens qui composent son
camp damien rieu un des fondateurs de
génération identitaire des mouvements
d'extrême droite quand il prend des gens
de la manif pour tous peut-être oui ça
c'est la droite conservatrice mais il a
aussi recruté des voix au rassemblement
national des gens qui sont classés
extrême droite lui c'est vrai il dit non
je ne suis pas d'extrême droite je suis
le camp des patriotes mais ça veut dire
quoi le camp des patriotes ça veut dire
que tous les autres ne sont pas des
patriotes tous les autres n'aiment pas
la france c'est une question ouverte en
tout cas c'est vrai que marine le pen
comme eric zemmour réfute cette
étiquette d'extrême droite autre chose
qui a choqué fait interpeller en tout
cas
hier lors de la grand meeting de eric
zemmour votre cadero la foule a scandé
macron assassin alors dans quel contexte
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé est
véritablement à ce moment là ce qui est
énormément de réactions là dessus il ya
beaucoup de réaction et c'est vrai qu'on
en a beaucoup parlé alors c'était un
moment où eric zemmour parler de
l'insécurité du problème de terrorisme
et c est là la foule a scandé macron
assassin mais moi j'ai aussi entendu à
la foule scandait un maquereau un
collabo et alors oui on en a beaucoup
parlé mais il faut dire que dans les
rassemblements ça arrive des
rassemblements politiques ça arrive moi
j'en ai déjà entendu notamment au front
national dans ton de ce genre de propos
alors peut-être qui avait pas autant de
monde qui le répétait c'est vrai que
cette fois ci avait des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et l'eczéma disait
semble donc c'est vrai que ça fait un
énorme échos la question c'est est ce
que eric zemmour on l'a entendu ou pas
ça c'est difficile à dire il faudrait le
dire directement faudrait demander
directement à eric zemmour mais lui dit
que tous les hommes politiques le savent
quand on est sur une estrade et qu'on
s'adresse à une foule comme ça c'est
très difficile de se concentrer dix ans
sur les messages qu'on reçoit mais bon
c'est vrai que en tout cas en tout cas
si on voit tant de si on doit parler
journal
à c si on doit parler des gens qui
étaient au place du trocadéro hier il y
avait vraiment de tout il y avait de la
droite conservatrice
des milieux ultra religieux enfin des
catholiques traditionalistes y avait
aussi des gens du front national des
gens beaucoup de familles des enfants il
y avait vraiment de tout il y avait
vraiment c'était un peu à l'image de ce
que le mouvement reconquête a réussi à
recruter vous avez des gens à droite
centre-droit droite conservatrice et les
extrêmes droites aussi c'était vraiment
un mélange de tout ça c'est un petit mot
sur marine le pen puisque tu couvres
l'extrême droite de manière dans sa
globalité disons donc marine le pen je
vous le rappelle la candidate du
rassemblement national bon là il était
en guadeloupe ce week-end a été
d'ailleurs chahuté par des militants
anti racistes lors de ce lors de ce
déplacement bois en tout cas elle
poursuit sa stratégie de dédiabolisation
qui semble très bien marché elle est
deuxième dans les intentions de vote
peut-être une réflexion sur sur cette
stratégie s'accompagne banon l'a suivi
depuis le début en fait depuis qu'elle a
pris les rênes du parti elle a essayé de
faire cette mutation se dé diabolisation
il faut se rappeler qu'à l'époque de son
père le front national c'était un parti
vraiment perçu comme extrémistes avec
des démesures des propos radicaux sur
sur l'islam mais aussi sur les locaux
sont se rappelle le détail de lits de
l'histoire etc
et marine le pen a essayé de se séparer
de cette étiquette de et aussi de l
amener des purges aussi il faut bien le
dire au sein de son parti elle s'est
débarrassée de ceux qui portaient des
voix un petit peu trop extrême on va
dire ou qu'ils maîtrisaient mal leur
langage qui commettait des erreurs et
qui disait des propos qui pouvaient
choquer et ben marine le pen ce qui est
étonnant c'est quand eric zemmour est
apparu tout le monde s'est dit bah ça va
être très compliquée pour marine le pen
parce qu'eric zemmour il arrivait à
casser cette image enfin il arrive à
recruter vraiment au sein de toute la
droite alors que beaucoup de gens se
disaient marine le pen elle est dans un
entonnoir elle est un petit peu à cerner
l est elle est piégée balah au contraire
elle a réussi à se rendre entre
guillemets sympathique c'est ce que
montre en tout cas les dernières études
elle a réussi à à à elle a même montré
aux des résultats notamment quand sa
nièce marion maréchal est parti du côté
de zemmour on l'a vu sur certaines
radios
coeur des pages peuvent cacher ça fait
mal pas tout ça c'est un visage qu'on
n'avait jamais vu alors est-ce que
c'était un trac voilà et est ce que
cette stratégie ou pas en tout cas on
peut imaginer que oui voir ça à sa nièce
partir chez l'opposant l'adversaire
numéro un qui arrête pas là tacler ça
fait mal mais en tout cas il semblerait
que marine le pen basse a fait son jeu
parce qu'elle est en train de monter
dans les sondages est elle pour
l'instant elle est loin loin devant eric
zemmour a encaissé que des sondages et
encore une fois l'équipe de zemmour dit
tout le temps mais les sondages sont
tout le temps trompé il l'a répété il
arrive et l'eczéma est il à dire moi je
suis le candidat de la vérité la vérité
c'est la france
les sondeurs les journalistes qu est ce
qu il a dit comme phrase notamment il a
dit pour les journalistes ma différence
c'est un problème c'est une faiblesse
mais pour le peuple c'est une qualité
alors que les sondages se trompent et
non plus il est persuadé qu'ils seront
sous mon toit on a un commentaire qui
nous dit la campagne française est archi
vide en dehors de l'immigration et des
musulmans on dirait que les candidats
n'ont pas de projet de société
bon sur leurs centres d'intérêts
champagne la presse ont partagé un com -
c'est vrai que c'est le sentiment le ce
que je ferai tout ce qui est peu de
débat véritablement de fond en l'absence
il y en a eu quelques-uns mort déjà sans
emmanuel macron donc sa position sur
l'avenir peut être changé c'est une
campagne un peu étrange avec la guerre
en ukraine et c'est vrai que ça a
écourté la campagne mais on peut parler
quand même d'autres thèmes il ya le
nucléaire qui divise les communistes
pour les écolos contre c'est très
compliqué le maquereau qui revient sur
ça il ya la réforme des retraites il ya
des mesures qui les thèmes majeurs est
absolument urgentissime comme le climat
le climat sa part voilà les énergies
renouvelables
alternatives castus et c'est toujours la
même chose si vous allez sur les sites
des candidats sur youtube vous regardez
leur discours en dire est qu'ils en
parlent après c'est vrai qu'on en parle
peut-être moins dans les débats mais
mais où c'est peut-être la faute des
journalistes qui met pas assez l'accent
sur ça peut-être que c'est le cas mais
pour les électeurs qui veulent vraiment
se sent fort mais ben vous regardez les
discours de chaque candidat les
manifester mais c'est vrai que le climat
on en parle peut être pas assez et c'est
un sujet qui qui forcément très
important merci infiniment que le risque
pour ce témoignage de retour du terrain
l'occurrence de ce meeting d'eric
zemmour hier mais je me rappelle un tu
couvres donc pour france 24
qui entraîne toi parce que là je dernier
reportage
suivant s'il a poussé comme un chien
pour dans le pardon
pour la force ce reportage que vous
pourrez donc visionner ce soir à
20h15 heure de paris donc dans ce
nouveau numéro de france 2020 de l'heure
du choix qu'on vous propose ce soir
merci encore clovis juste pour dire que
c'est sur les fillonnistes qui ont qui
était chez les républicains et qui ont
rejoint eric zemmour donc on voit là et
qu'ils étaient donc hier à la
manifestation d'eric zemmour dont
d'ailleurs tous les reportages de clovis
soit retrouvée bien évidemment sur notre
site internet merci beaucoup
lovis merci à vous tous qui nous on voit
là vous nous avez déjà posé énormément
de questions sur notamment l'extrême
droite mais pas que sur cette
présidentielle 2022 de manière générale
merci à ceux qui nous rejoignent à
l'instant pour ce live je vous le
rappelle ce live vous est dédié à vous
les internautes vous nous et clovis est
passé devant la caméra salut que le
risque
il vous est dédié donc vous pouvez nous
poser toutes toutes vos questions sur
facebook youtube instagram sur les
enjeux de cette présidentielle sur les
coulisses de notre émission là à
l'instant j'ai pas mal de questions tout
simplement sur les dates du scrutin je
vous le rappelle donc le premier tour
c'est le 10 avril et le second tour le
24 avril 2022 donc un scrutin en deux
tours et ma collègue marie schuster
autres reporters terrain ma désormais
rejoint salut paris merlus en reporter
anne des bajaus tout ça à tâtons
accréditation voilà exactement merger et
son mari dans le ring ouais on le sait
bien merci beaucoup marine nous avoir
rejoint donc dans ce live avec clovis on
a pas mal parlé voilà tu l'as entendu de
l'extrême droite de l'atmosphère de
cette campagne toi donc tu couvres le
centre en l'occurrence la campagne des
manuels macro emmanuel macron de lui
donc le président sortant le président
candidat
n'a pas fait de meetings sont
premier meeting ce sera seulement le 2
avril les manières il n'a pas non plus
débattus enfin tout cas qui ne souhaite
pas débattre avant le premier tour avec
ses concurrents ce qui suscite
énormément de critiques de la part des
autres candidats et puis aussi d'une
partie grosse partie de la population il
explique aussi que ses prédécesseurs à
la voile alors que j'allais te demander
bon ça fait beaucoup réagir à ce qu en
soit c'est inédit non c'est pas du tout
inédit puisque effectivement ses
prédécesseurs n'avaient avait refusé de
débattre dans
avant le premier tour c'est à dire que
les débats étaient installés à partir du
second tour donc de là on peut
effectivement penser qu emmanuel macron
même s'il ne veut pas l'avouer à haute
voix se pense au second tour et
permettra le débat peut-être avant le
second tour alors là pas mal de
questions là tout simplement là pour
rappeler donc les dates du scrutin je
les dis le 10 et 24 avril et puis aussi
pour donner la liste des candidats alors
en tête donc on à emmanuel macron
ensuite marine le pen et puis jean luc
mélenchon à la griserie et jacques
zemmour et alors là la grande question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est non pas
est-ce que emmanuel macron fera partie
au sera au second tour mais qui sera au
second tour à ses côtés et donc on voit
bien une montée comme l'expliqué clovis
un petit peu plus tôt une montée de
l'extrême droite donc 2 marine le pen
dans les sondages alors que va la
dynamique des manuels macron petit à
petit ça fesse alors évidemment il reste
très haut dans les sondages puisque je
crois que les derniers sondages s'est il
est placé à 28% mais bon les gars pour
pourrait se rapprocher et le gain
troisième position potentiellement il
pourrait y avoir leur candidat de la
france insoumise et jean luc jean luc
mélenchon tafer vous avez pour évoquer
un autre candidat écologiste yannick
jadot vous avez là dans les intentions
je sais pas pourquoi je te vous vois
dans les intentions de vote lie les deux
mémoires en sixième position il à 5%
d'intentions de vote selon les derniers
sondages qui date du 25 mars je crois et
c'est vrai que là moi j'étais hier au
meeting de yannick jadot zénith à paris
est bon c'est vrai que les verts étaient
très comment dire très content d'avoir
atteint cette espèce de deux meetings
gigantesques ils ont annoncé tonitruant
que c'était le plus grand meeting du
parti depuis son existence oui mais
3500 4000 militants dans le zénith voilà
j'avais quand même des confrères qui le
disaient c'est quand même très
surprenant que ce soit aussi peu la
campagne de janot a le sentiment qu'elle
a du mal à décoller comment tu te
l'expliquer alors on le disait alors le
thème du climat est très très peu
abordés dans cette campagne en par cette
question des énergies renouvelables
qu'on a on finalement abordé seulement
parce qu'il y avait cette histoire de
gaz une alternative au gaz russe etc
mais au final bon les la thématique
climatique a pas du tout pris comment
est-ce que tu t'expliques par ailleurs
alors je peux revenir un petit peu aussi
si tu veux sur base sur le meeting de
jado au hyères c'est à dire que moi j'ai
été très étonné de voir yannick jadot
qui ne sauve pas du tout sur cette vague
de la multiplication des rapports du
giec
et qui pourrait justement emboîté le pas
pour qu'il présente un certain nombre de
propositions
concrètes justement pour sur cette
question climatique en fait ils yannick
jadot lui sait qu en dira davantage
concentré sur la guerre en ukraine en
expliquant que depuis toujours les
écologistes avaient avait expliqué que
poutine n'était pas une personne
fréquentable et c est plutôt que de
justement d'aller finalement sur leur
coeur de métier c'est à dire défendre
l'écologie et faire des propositions
concrètes sur l'écologie et on voit on
ne tire pas assez la semaine elles ont
alors tiré la sonnette d'alarmé pense
que tout le monde le fait aujourd'hui
fin non mais avec ma position contre
voilà les propositions concrètes qu'on
pourrait attendre d'un parti écologiste
sont pas énoncer réellement est ce qui
est assez choquant dans la mesure où qui
d'autre que le parti écologiste pourrait
présenter des propositions sur le climat
alors bouclé les idées restent très
abstraite et
c'était ça qui était assez étonnant
alors parmi les autres propositions de
yannick jadot on le sait il ya cette
légalisation du cannabis et on a
justement une question merci beaucoup de
l'avoir posée sur le sujet alors c'est
thomas snark à qui nous dit juste là les
gagner la légalisation du cannabis 4
points d'interrogation alors si on veut
un petit peu reprendre cette rebondir
sur cette question
yannick jadot donc la propose qu'en est
il des manuels macron alors emmanuel
macron lui n'est pas pour la
légalisation
du cannabis à proprement dit puisque il
ya beaucoup de candidats qui sont qui
sont un petit peu comment dire un petit
peu embêté avec cette question de
légalisation du cannabis
par contre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
cette question de la légalisation du
cannabis est
presque au coeur de la campagne de
yannick jadot puisque c'est celle pour
laquelle il s'est fait le plus acclamé
hier au zénith ce qui est quand même
très étonnant en ce qui concerne les
autres candidats que ce soit jean luc
mélenchon emmanuel macron ou fabien
roussel ou les autres on a sept
justement cette question qui reste un
petit peu quand dira en attente c'est à
dire qu'on ne veut pas la légalisation
du cannabis mais en même temps on va
essayer de faire des choses pour que ça
ne devienne pas un trafic qui créerait
de l'insécurité dans les quartiers un
petit peu sensible enfin voilà il ya un
espèce de discours un peu
[Musique]
d'équilibriste entre pour les clés les
candidats sur cette question cruciale
apparemment du cannabis une autre
question pour toi marie est ce que
l'apparent refus de débat d'emmanuel
macron fin de débattre pourrait
contribuer à sa réélection en avait fait
deux trois questions
quand même sur une probable réélection
d'emmanuel accroît leur est ce que le
fait voilà qu'ils ne soient pas jetés
d'emblée dans l'arène
alors a contribué au fait qu'ils soient
intouchables alors ce que disent les
opposants d'emmanuel macron c'est que le
fait qu'il refuse le débat lui permet de
ne pas être interrogée sur son bilan en
tant que président voilà et finalement
ça fait aussi les affaires entre
guillemets d emmanuel macron de ne pas
débattre sur son bilan présidentiel
puisque lui permet
ça lui permet de débattre en tout cas
d'avancé les arguments de son bilan en
tant que chef de guerre
puisque aujourd'hui il est au coeur de
des négociations entre l'ukraine et sur
ce point aussi on a énormément de
réactions notamment alors celle que
j'hésitais déjà tout à l'heure de fréjus
master key
sur instagram qui demandait pensez vous
que l'implication des maniaques on dans
le conflit en ukraine pourrait aller
dans son sens pour la présidentielle tu
as le sentiment qu effectivement il y en
est ressorti
avantagé alors d'une certaine manière
oui parce que sur le terrain les gens
que nous avons rencontrés avec ma
collègue claire pas quelqu'un qui suit
pour la chaîne anglophone la campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel macron avec
moi nous avons rencontré donc des
habitants des électeurs potentiels qui
nous explique qu'effectivement il
n'avais que ça en tête la guerre en
ukraine trop totalement paralysée par
les éventuelles conséquences que peuvent
avoir cette guerre en ukraine que peut
avoir cette guerre en ukraine
terrorisée même de ne pas en sortir
vainqueur si j'ose dire et même d'avoir
un seuil comment dire une baisse des
richesses 1 pen des pertes d'emplois
voilà des prix qui flambent donc voilà
ils sont terrorisés par cette question
ukrainienne est dès lors eu 10 bat
écouter les autres candidats on les a
pas testé emmanuel macron est déjà en
poste lui il des
[Musique]
relations privilégiées déjà avec le
président zelensky et vladimir poutine
donc c'est alors au point de vue ses
parents changent pas de settat de leader
est exactement c'est à dire que si les
gens aujourd'hui des leçons du sentiment
que j'ai pu en avoir sur le terrain si
les gens votent pour emmanuel macron
c'est plutôt par défaut que par
conviction et aujourd'hui c'est
justement la campagne des manuels macron
la stratégie c'est d'essayer de
transformer ce vote d'essayer de faire
en sorte que ils votent les gens votent
pour lui par conviction et non pas par
défaut
est ce que tu dirais du coup qu'il a un
boulevard devant lui ou pour autant
faire alors ces équipes disent attention
l'abstention alors l'abstention on va y
venir c'est un gros problème je pense
que enfin en tout cas les observateurs
craignent véritablement un taux
d'abstention record notamment chez les
jeunes pour cette présidentielle qui a
décidément eu beaucoup de mal à
intéresser
mais pour autant est ce que tu dirais
qu'il a un boulevard devant lui
alors est-ce qu'il a un boulevard devant
lui l'élection présidentielle en france
est toujours un peu étonnante on a eu
des on a eu des élections
présidentielles qui
qu'ils ont eue qui avait des prévisions
voilà
avancer comme ça et puis on s'est
retrouvé avec un deuxième tour on a tous
été un peu
étonné et si ce n'est choqué du résultat
donc voilà je m'appelle pas madame irma
malheureusement mais je sais pas si
effectivement emmanuel macron un
boulevard devant lui et que il peut être
réélu passé le second tour être passé le
premier tour est réélu au second tour
maintenant c'est vrai que le contexte
actuel international joue clairement
pour lui et puis et puis on n'a pas
alors à part peut-être cette petite
enfance ce scandale cette polémique sur
mackenzie pour l'instant on a et on va
revenir là quelques minutes avec marc
parent exactement on n'a pas de deux
choses qui pourraient peser vraiment
dans la campagne contre lui tu me disais
tout à l'heure en off que la campagne de
macron selon toi était verrouillée
qu'est-ce que tu entendez par là mais la
campagne l'équipe de campagne cas de
l'as complètement la campagne des
manuels macron c'est à dire que
évidemment les journalistes sont invités
à se rendre aux conférences de presse
aux réunions publiques
de manière assez ouverte mais une fois
qu'on n'arrive sur place et bien on se
rend compte que banon on peut pas filmer
certaines choses ça ces images sont dits
poulet c'est à dire que ce sont des des
médias qui sont choisis pour pour faire
ces images où ce sont des l'équipe de
campagne c'est l'équipe de campagne
elle-même qui filme le candidat et les
interactions et je peux vous raconter
une petite anecdote je me suis déplacé à
poissy pour ce premier rassemblement
public
cette rencontre entre emmanuel macron et
ses habitants de poids si on nous avait
indiqué que les caméras n'étaient pas
autorisés à l'intérieur et j'ai eu
l'audace de présenter mon téléphone
portable un petit peu comme ça pour
faire une photo voilà pour les réseaux
sociaux et j'ai eu immédiatement
un un membre de l'équipe de campagne qui
m'a sauté dessus en disant non non pas
de photos pas de vidéo donc à l'image
d'emmanuel macron est extrêmement
contrôlé aujourd'hui et et je pense
aussi c'est une espèce de deux
d'amalgamé entre ce qu'il faut faire
pour le président ce qu'il faut faire
pour le candidat voilà on a vraiment
face de nous un président candidat et
non pas un candidat président merci
beaucoup marie jeu car sympa d'être
passés nous voir donc pour nous livrer
ton sentiment sur de manière générale
sur cette campagne et puis précisément
sur les campagne du président candidat
emmanuel macron et puis sur yannick
jadot le candidat écologiste merci
encore peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion
de te retrouver dans ce live on l'espère
en tout cas bien sûr vous pouvez suivre
marie et puis regardez ses reportages
sur le site internet de france 24 sur
notre antenne bien sûr et puis surtout
les réseaux sociaux merci beaucoup marie
je te libère
merci à vous tous qui êtes toujours là
très très nombreux en live temps seul
youtube que sur facebook vous l'avez vu
j'ai posé pas mal déjà de vos questions
elles continuent de nous parvenir merci
infiniment à ceux qui contribuent
donc n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions sur je vous le rappelle les
coulisses de france 2022 lors du choix
sur les grands enjeux de cette
présidentielle 2022 en france sur les
voilà des les coups durs de cette
campagne ses temps forts je suis à
présent
rejoindre par marc perelman salut marque
merci de passer nous voir donc pour ce
troisième live un consacré la
présidentielle en france je rappelle en
toi tu es un peu on acolytes côté
anglophone tuer le présentateur de
france
twenty twente et tout comme thème
j'espère que j'ai bien prononcer
portrait voilà donc vous pouvez suivre
tous les épisodes de marque
également sur le site internet de france
24 est bien sûr donc en direct sur la
chaîne anglo tous les soirs marque tout
d'abord peut-être un sentiment général
sur cette campagne on l'a un peu dit
déjà avec clovis et et marie le
sentiment que l d'école à peine
quel regard est ce que tu portes sur
cette campagne peut-être par rapport à
des campagnes que tu as couvert dans le
passé c'est vrai que c'est une drôle de
campagne comme on a pu parler d'une
drôle de guerre à une autre époque à
notre siècle parce qu'elle commence très
très tard on est à moins de 15 jours et
c'est vrai qu'entre on va leur dire
encore une fois mais c'est vrai entre la
pandémie la guerre en ukraine la
campagne a été anesthésiée alors au
grand dam de l'opposition qui dit qu
emmanuel macron il y avait eu tout son
intérêt et a donc fait en sorte d'être
le moins possible candidat est le plus
possible président lui dit qu'il n'a pas
le choix mais c'est vrai que
la campagne et en plus comme les
sondages laissent assez peu de suspense
ou en tout cas laissé assez peu de
suspens jusqu'à peut-être ces derniers
jours sauf pour la deuxième place et
encore c'est vrai que les gens se sont
dit de toute façon ces jouets est donc
moindre mobilisation à cause des
conditions sanitaires
à cause de la guerre en ukraine à cause
du manque du de suspense mais c'est vrai
que ça va sans doute accélérer là on a
déjà pu le voir ce week-end parce que
peut-être que tout n'est pas joué il ya
encore beaucoup de points
d'interrogation l'abstention peut-être
un vote elle s'affiche d'accord ça non
ce record mais il faut quand même être
prudent s'il ya bien une élection où les
gens votent en france c'est la
présidentielle mais c'est vrai que il ya
aussi cette question du vote utile c'est
vrai que traditionnellement le vote
utile c'est celui qu'on fait au deuxième
tour on vote au premier tour avec son
coeur et au deuxième tour avec ses
intérêts ou diront les mauvaises langues
avec son portefeuille mais là il
semblerait qu'il y ait une volonté
peut-être de voter utile dès le premier
tour c'est ce que veulent évidemment les
favoris emmanuel macron marine le pen
vous même jean luc mélenchon quand même
pas mal de questions toute basique 1 sur
le nombre de candidats en lice dans
cette élection il y en a douze bien la
douce c'est vrai que ça a été de
l'extrême droite aux trotskistes ah oui
il ya vraiment tout le spectre y compris
ceux qui pendant des semaines ont crié
au scandale parce qu'il faut obtenir
c'est 500 parrainages d'élus c'est vrai
que eric zemmour marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon ont averti qu'il n'allait pas
voir ses parrainages qu'il devait avoir
une crise démocratique très grave même
on a vu le gouvernement un petit peu
paniqué dire oui il faudrait que
certains élus de notre camp par end ou
le monde pour que l'élection soit normal
finalement
tout le monde est sur la ligne de départ
y compris des candidats qui n'ont aucune
chance d'être au second tour donc c'est
vrai qu'on va de l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche alors il ya pas mal de
questions marque aujourd'hui concernant
ce potentiel scandale mckinsey alors il
ya nico provins tout d'abord qui nous
qui nous écrit merci beaucoup nico
provins pour cette question pourquoi est
ce qu emmanuel macron est aussi haut
dans les sondages alors que nico provins
qualifie de bidon alors qu' il y à ce
scandale d'état impliquant le cabinet
mckinsey scandale qui est rendu
inaudible autre question va plutôt
commentaire sur ce scandale qu'on va
maintenant expliqué ensemble un marc de
doni 26,85 on est au bord du scandale
d'état encore là une autre qui me
parvient est ce que le citoyen peut voir
le rapport mckinsey donc
écho à ce rapport d'une commission
sénatoriale que tu va maintenant nous
expliquer c'est quoi ce cette affaire
matinée alors si on était simple oui on
va essayer de faire simple il y à une
commission d' enquête du sénat qui a
donc travaillé qui a rendu un rapport le
17 mars sur le rôle de ces cabinets de
conseil privé qui sont souvent des
appuis à des politiques publiques mises
en place que les gouvernements les
administrations
consultent et paye évidemment parce
qu'ils ne font rien gratuit raison parce
que c'est leur raison d'être de
conseillers contre un prix souvent assez
élevé et donc il ya une enquête qui a
été fait sur l'utilisation notamment
depuis plusieurs années en gros sous la
présidence macron et on en est les ceux
qui ont enquêté au sénat ont trouvé
selon la commission denquête ces
contrats entre l'état et cabinets ont
plus que doublé entre 2018 et 2020 et on
parle de plus d'un milliard d'euros en
commun qui ont été
payés alors il ya toutes sortes de
contrats parce qu'il ya toutes sortes
d'administration et maclean's est
notamment pointé du doigt parce qu'ils
ont été ils ont perçu quelques 12
millions d'euros dans la lutte contre la
pandémie notamment la mise en place de
la stratégie vaccinale parce qu'il faut
se souvenir aujourd'hui presque tout le
monde est vacciné mais au début il n'y
avait pas de vaccin il y avait une
inquiétude et donc les gouvernements
sans doute essayer de trouver et de
consulter voilà il ya eu il ya aussi
dans ce rapport quelque chose qui a
beaucoup réagir c'est que mckeen's elle
a touché 4 millions d'euros pour un
rapport sur remédier aux difficultés
informatiques a lié à la réforme des apl
les apl cdz personnalités au logement 4
millions d'euros pour ça ou cinq cent
mille euros pour étudier la le statut
des enseignants en france dont le
responsable de mckinsey a affirmé au
sénat qui ne savait pas trop à quoi il
avait servi
donc il ya cette idée me c'est aussi
parce que ce cabinet apparemment n'a pas
payé là alors d'une part il ya les
prestations pourquoi est ce que le
gouvernement ne fait pas ce travail il
aime le gouvernement réponde à une idée
on est trop cucquois là on est contre
occupés on nous demande de couper les
coûts depuis des années on ne peut pas
tout faire on ne sait pas tout ferme
autant demander à ceux qui savent oui ça
coûte cher mais peut-être que ça nous
permet aussi de faire des économies par
ailleurs l'autre problème en effet et
c'est pour ça que certains parlent de
scandale d'état notamment les les
insoumis ils se sont saisis de fabien
roussel fabien roussel évidemment logist
c'est que par ailleurs contrairement à
ce qu'a déclaré le responsable de
mckinsey qui a été interrogée par cette
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale ils
n'ont pas payé d'impôt sur les sociétés
depuis au moins dix ans d'après le
rapport d' enquête alors pourquoi il
s'agit de stratégie d'optimisation
fiscale c'est à dire que mes gars comme
la maison-mère de mckinsey et aux états
unis il y à des transferts d'argent
entre les deux qui leur permettent en
gros de ne pas se retrouver dans la
situation où ils deviennent un
contribuable français alors évidemment
ça mais quand même le doute chez
certains évidemment à gauche voire
l'extrême gauche en disant qu'est ce que
c'est que ces manières c'est de
l'optimisation fiscale en fait c'est la
fraude fiscale avec la complicité des
autorités françaises qui font semblant
de ne pas voir c'est vrai que bruno le
maire le ministre des finances a été
obligé de dire oui oui vous inquiétez
pas ils vont payer ce qu'ils nous
doivent mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un
sentiment de malaise et pour terminer
parce que c'est pour ça que certains en
parlent de scandale d'état il y à une
suspicion il y avait un article dans le
monde l'an passé qui parlait de certains
liens entre le président macron et
mckinsey qui l'auraient aidé pendant la
campagne de 2010 7la en effet où ça
pourrait devenir beaucoup plus venimeux
entre guillemets pour emmanuel macron
sait si il y a eu du favoritisme pour
l'instant il n'y a aucune trace de
favoritisme et emmanuel macron a réagi
lui-même dimanche en disant s'il ya un
problème il faut aller au pénal et c'est
là que ça doit se juger et refuse toute
cette suspicion qui est jeté sur lui à
travers ces accusations alors peut-être
qu'on peut un peu s'attarder cette fois
qu'on n'a pas encore parlé de jean luc
mélenchon le conte est de la france
insoumis c'est sa troisième candidature
si c'est vraiment la dernière financière
on va voir à quoi il a 70 ans et joe
biden bien plus
voilà alors on a une question de magie à
baali bonjour madières ben ali merci
nous poser une question que pensez vous
pardon que pensez-vous oui j'imagine de
la politique de jean luc mélenchon
président pour ce qui est du non
alignement de la france la france ne
doit elle pas être le gendarme du monde
le gendarme du monde je ne pense pas je
pense que jean luc mélenchon ne le pense
pas non plus par contre sur l'idée du
non-alignement alors c'est quoi cette
idée cette idée c'est une idée qu'il a
du mal à exprimer en ce moment parce que
voilà pour lui le non-alignement c'est à
dire que la france ne doit pas être
alignée sur les états unis c'est ce
qu'il veut dire voilà alors évidemment
il a été mise en difficulté comme marine
le pen ou eric zemmour de l'autre côté
de la scène politique par sa supposée
proximité c'est pas le cas mais sa
supposée ça passe ainsi complaisance
envers vladimir poutine qui serait dû à
son parcours gauchistes et donc
attachement quelque part à l'urss ou
communisme aux choses comme ça et c'est
vrai que il a été mis en difficulté
parce que il a des positions qui sont un
petit peu différente qu'il assume lui il
faut y aller à fond qu'il faut sortir de
l'otan sur la question des livraisons
d'armes lui il affirme que livrer des
armes à l'ukraine c'est une erreur c'est
de rajouter de la guerre à la guerre
donc il assume cette position mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une volonté de revenir un
petit peu à une france qui est
indépendante alors ça peut rappeler
aussi de gaulle d'une certaine façon
même si ce n'est clairement pas la tasse
de thé de jean luc mélenchon alors autre
question cette fois sur la compagne
d'emmanuelle macron elles nous viennent
d' alvin
dia joue d'iag et je ne sais pas comment
prononcer un désolé de mamie sur une
question posée sur facebook pourquoi on
est ce qu'on ne voit pas emmanuel macron
faire campagne comme le fait un candidat
comme eric zemmour après parce que déjà
ils sont très différents mais aussi
parce que manuel macron même s'il a dit
ce week-end qu'il le regrette qui veut
aller au contact quelque chose comme ça
il n'a tout simplement pas le temps la
semaine dernière était une parfaite
illustration
il a passé une journée à bruxelles
sommet de l'otan sommet du g7 sommet de
l'union européenne
évidemment il ne peut pas faire campagne
c'est très difficile n'y aura
normalement qu'un meeting prévu après le
pardon avant le premier tour à paris à
la défense ces jeux historiques jamais
un candidat alors il ya quelques
réunions là oui c'est vrai que là ils
prêtent le flanc à la critique parce que
il a fait une réunion dans les yvelines
à poissy puis à pau chez son allié
centriste françois bayrou et c'est un
peu une réunion entre copains c'est à
dire que les questions
elles ne piquent pas beaucoup comme on
quand on dit donc ça c'est vrai qu'il ya
voilà mais emmanuel macron et quelqu'un
enfin pour le court il a beaucoup de
défauts mais pas celui d'éviter la
baston s'il faut enfin il argumentation
c'est quelque chose qui qui lui plaît on
l'avait vu pendant la campagne
2010 est quand il avait été dans cette
usine où ça s'était pas forcément bien
passé au début choses comme ça mais
c'est vrai que il est empêché par
d'abord par la pandémie maintenant par
l'ukraine mais c'est vrai que ça arrange
bien ça énerve beaucoup ses adversaires
à tel point que le président du sénat
gérard larcher l'a accusé en gros de
vouloir enjambées l'élection ça ne lui a
pas plu du tout mais on peut quand même
penser que dans les derniers jours
emmanuel macron descendra plus
directement dans l'arène et se mettra un
peu plus à hauteur de de ses adversaires
mais pour l'instant les sondages lui
donnent raison mais il ya quand même
quelques signaux d alerte autour de lui
il les 10 ty d'ailleurs lui-même que
l'excès de confiance peut nuire que
cette impression que de toute façon il a
gagné peut être dangereuse peut être
néfaste déjà pour sa réélection tout le
monde a participé à la guerre tension et
ça peut véritablement le oui oui ça peut
le desservir ça peut aussi desservir
d'autres candidats on sait que jean luc
mélenchon a toujours dit avant de
remonter dans les sondages qui le
placent désormais en troisième position
que lui craint beaucoup la
démobilisation notamment dans les
quartiers populaires où il sait qu'il
peut avoir ses soutiens le même souci
pour marine le pen marine le pen craint
beaucoup l'abstention rappelez-vous aux
élections régionales le le rassemblement
national était bien placé les sondages
le donnaient vainqueur de quelques
régions résultat en raison de
l'abstention avant tout ça a été la
bérézina donc il y à une crainte qui est
peut-être moindre chez emmanuel macron
ou valérie pécresse par exemple ou même
chez eric zemmour 1 parce que c'est des
catégories sociologiques qui sont
généralement plus aisées plus âgés qui
donc vote plus alors que c'est jean luc
mélenchon chez marine le pen c'est
plutôt des populations à moindres
revenus des jeunes qui le jour du
scrutin s'ils ont autre chose à faire
elles n'iront pas forcément mettre leur
bulletin c'est une dernière question
marque un tout autre chose
avec l'élection d'un nouveau président
en france donc si ce n'est pas emmanuel
macron la france va-t-elle quitter
l'afrique
alors là là là vous posez une colle je
pense que je ne vois pas vraiment en
dehors de eric zemmour
marine le pen donc référence un éventuel
désengagement encore plus poussée voilà
ce française j'imagine oui je le sais
j'imagine que c'est que ça que ça c'est
vrai que s'il ya vraiment une rupture
j'allais dire idéologiques voire sans
doute des tensions très vives c'est
zemmour qui a clairement
il a parlé de l'algérie où on a vu
marion maréchal-le pen qui l'a rejoint
qui parle souvent de la france qui
risque de devenir africaine la lah en
effet il risque d'y avoir une gros clash
entre j'ai à dire la france et beaucoup
de pays africains
avec marine le pen il y aura évidemment
des tensions il y aurait peut-être sans
doute en effet une tentation
souverainistes de dire mais pourquoi est
ce que nos soldats vont se battre au
mali si en plus on n'en veut pas donc
autant autant les ramener à la maison
pour protéger la patrie contre tous les
dangers qui l'entourent voilà mais
enfin si c'est jean luc mélenchon
valérie pécresse ou évidemment à fort
sur emmanuel macron il y aura peut-être
quelques changements mais la france et
l'afrique ne sont séparés que de
quelques kilomètres qui l'ont destin lié
c'est parfois difficile c'est parfois
compliqué mais c'est comme ça que ça se
passe merci beaucoup marc d'avoir
participé à cela et c'est sympa d'être
venu nous voir et d'avoir donc apporter
tous ces éclairages sur la
présidentielle en france merci à vous
tous d'avoir contribué avec vos
commentaires vos questions à ce live
c'était vraiment très intéressant pour
nous je vous remercie à vous tous vous
nous avez écrit depuis le maroc depuis
pointe noire depuis la république
démocratique du congo la guinée
équatoriale
également ou encore le gabon merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi on fera
bientôt bien sûr un quatrième live donc
sur cette présidentielle hésitez pas en
attendant n'hésitez pas à nous débriefer
1 de ce troisième live sur les réseaux
sociaux en attendant pour ma part je
vous donne rendez-vous donc d'ici
quelques heures pour un nouvel épisode
de france 2022 l'heure du choix c'est ce
soir à 20h15 heure de paris on vous
attend nombreux
à tout à l'heure au revoir
[Musique]